Wir haben besonders unsere Kategorie,
sie heißt Fragenlotterie und die
grünen sind sehr, sehr nette Fragen
mit vielen Komplimenten darin und die
Nassen, ich denke, Sie können sich vorstellen, ist ein
bisschen verrückt, es ist ein bisschen
provozierend, okay, fangen wir mit
a an  rot Okay ich werde nicht mal schauen sagen wir mal
was ist das oh du hast ein
grünes also kannst du es öffnen und die
frage lesen ob dir gefällt was ich gar nicht
hast du hast eine bemerkenswerte karriere du warst
ein sportstar model  Und jetzt, Nektar, wie
oft stehst du vor dem Memo
und sagst dir, ja, heiße Sachen, ich stehe nicht hier und mache das, an dem
Tag, an dem ich es tue
, ist das ein
trauriger Tag  Tage, an denen du sagst, oh, ich kann es nicht
glauben, aber das ist wahr, es ist nicht das,
was sie in dieser Richtung denken,
denn du weißt, was Erfolg ist, ist eine
vorübergehende Sache, du weißt, es ist, als ob das, was
nach oben geht, nach unten kommt und du du selbst sein
musst  müssen sich bewusst sein, dass es nicht in
Ihrer Kontrolle liegt, also y  Du solltest es sein,
du musst es zu schätzen wissen, dass die Leute
deine Filme sehen wollen, aber du weißt,
dass das nicht immer der Fall ist, du weißt, dass
manchmal der Geschmack einfach
nicht mehr gut schmeckt, also bin
ich dankbarer  weil
ich in einem Job bin, der ein wenig
unvorhersehbar ist okay nächste Frage du kannst dir
eine aussuchen da gibt es viel
Geld auszugeben das ist nicht meine Frage also sei bitte
nett zu mir du machst nur Actionfilme
willst du nicht  andere Filme machen, wie
in einem Drama mitzuspielen. Ich habe kürzlich einen Film mit dem
Titel „Hummingbird“ gedreht, mit einem
sehr, sehr berühmten Schriftsteller
in Großbritannien, sein Name ist Steven Knight
ersten Film und
wir haben ihn letztes Jahr in London gedreht und ich bin
wirklich sehr stolz darauf, es ist
etwas, das viele Emotionen hat
, die ich nie ausdrücken kann,
es ist definitiv ein Schritt in eine Richtung
, die ich gesucht habe  mach ok gut
luc  k für die letzte Frage
vielleicht Rhett erstaunlich wir möchten alle, dass
Sie der beliebteste Actionstar
unserer Zeit sind, wie spektakulär der
Alltag mit Jason Statham ist, wie spektakulär der
Alltag ist, überhaupt nicht so spektakulär,
es ist wie bei jedem anderen, wissen Sie
, ja, ich  neige dazu, alle meine Freunde
von dir fernzuhalten, seit ich
alle am selben Ort aufgewachsen bin und sich nichts
geändert
hat
Ich arbeite die
ganze Zeit
, das ist das einzige, alles andere
scheint gleich zu sein, okay, vielen Dank,
okay,
du